cool I think thank you process good
morning everyone so hope you are all
settled down
jerk-off face and brakes so today I'm
going to talk about visual contest
concept learning basically what Chris
was told from few images just my brief
introduction I currently work for a
clown and now I lead the fraud division
and I lead the data science division as
well in the Berlin office I till last
week I was working with oil X group and
the moderation team basically dealing
with moderation short in 40 to 50
countries 55 sites on a big scale my
past history is basically basically
working in multiple software industries
and it last five years I've moved
towards machine learning hey if you want
to contact me
there's my lingering address it's on
also on the last slide as well so if you
have any questions later on you can put
put the questions there so what I'm
going to talk about today what is
basically a few short learning no short
or one-shot whatever that is
some popular data sets that people are
actually using to do to do the current
research some approaches that have been
that are popular approaches that you can
use to solve this kind of problems some
previous path some previous related work
that is quite inspiring and finally some
paper summaries I'm going to talk about
four papers today basically like
five-minute introductions for each of
these papers so 0 and few short learning
what is it all about so it is about
learning how to represent objects in our
cases images from very little samples
like very few instances of each object
it can range from zero you haven't seen
any of these images before one you have
seen one instance of these objects and
and so on you can see five instances of
these objects twenty instances of these
objects let's say I give you an example
often a fixed animal call a tree bruh it
is a zebra but with red stripes and I
show you one example of this image as a
human you'll be I hope you will be able
to distinguish all the arriba images
into
from a stack of images so let's see I
for the next slides I'm going to test on
humans right now I'm going to show you
some examples of images and finally I'm
going to ask you to predict what the
animal is ok so let's see how the human
performs one small thing these images
are coming from both panda and I do
really do not know the intensity of
these images or the animals so please do
not quote me on that the first one is a
pink fairy armadillo okay the next one
is the Dumbo octopus third one is the
Patagonian Mara fourth one a lamprey
fifth one a star-nosed mole so now comes
the test what is this animal any answers
second if someone's in second Alaska so
what you see here is like you haven't
seen in previous examples of this animal
before so this is called a zero short
learning now a machine can be asked what
what kind of animal is this it is
actually a fish it is called a block
fish but the next one let's see what is
this one see very nice it's a Patagonian
Mara and see the humans are performing
really well so the concepts next que
shot anyway this is a very basic concept
in fuse for learning and is the number
of classes that you can predict from K
is the number of instances that you're
shown so for an example too short for
cover for a classification you have four
classes of colors and for each color you
have got two instances and from this the
Machine needs to learn which color the
difference images from so what did he
learn too now that humans can learn new
concepts very fast without much training
data I just showed you one animal and
you were able to predict that but for
deep learning in neural networks you
need to show lots of examples maybe
hundreds maybe thousands maybe multiples
of thousands
typically that leads us to the
motivation for a few short learning
typically what happens is if you just
train an inception net or ResNet the
dense net whatever that is for one-shot
learning it basically all fits heck even
if you give hundreds of examples it will
still all fit
so if your training from scratch neural
networks has millions of parameters this
gives us the advantage that you can
learn multiple a multiple number of
functions you can generalize or if you
show a lot of examples but for one-shot
learning it basically is disastrous
because it over fits on the on the
sample dataset and that is the first
point it fails to generalize second
thing getting labeled data is expensive
expensive in terms of time expensive in
the terms of money you can ask
Mechanical Turk to label later images
then you need to verify then you need to
clean you can ask universities to give
you data like comp cars there are
multiple different sources that you can
tack vetting at that you can retrieve
data from but there's always like time
and cleaning information and cleaning
the data sorry third thing adding domain
information or feature information for
your images let's say you're defining
the quality of an image how do you do
that either train a neural network or
add more features on top of it to say
what is contrast for this color what the
brightness is so these kind of features
if you add to your network it it is kind
of it's not scale up well for other
kinds of objects or other kinds of
images fourthly the thing is all these
gradient descent methods that are
currently employed in CNN's these are
just not made for to work on the car to
work under the constraint of a less
number of samples so you need to give a
lot of sample so that it can properly
gradient descent and finally lowest
minimum in your loss so the last thing
is when you are training a neural
network you kind of randomly initialize
the weights of your new networks this
also hampers your training because in
order to converge it it needs a lot of a
box so if you if you have proper
initialization of way
it your networks can converge faster so
these are some of the problems that are
being solved using few short learning so
some of the popular datasets that people
are actually using that researchers are
actually using to solve this problem the
first one is called Omniglot this was
made by Bernard Lake in 2015
these images are basically 100 and 105
105 grayscale images in a total they're
1623 characters from 50 alphabets and
each character is handwritten by 20
humans so for each one thousand six one
thousand characters you have 20
handwritten images that you can learn
from the alphabets range from different
languages Hebrew and there are some
pictures languages as well
Futurama or at bay a thing here and the
second delay the newspapers like from
the last year they are currently using
imagenet mini mesh net because they
resemble more real life pictures
Omniglot is like the amnesty of future
few short learning some approaches and
related work so there are two basic
approaches that you can use to do few
short learning as in if you have
constraint of number of samples first
thing is data based this is very easy
and practical as well and the second
thing is metric or parameter based which
I'm going to talk about next data based
I I touched on this topic before but you
can tap into external sources basically
can download images from Google search
you can download images from if you have
a lines with the University you can get
some data from there and you can also
pay some companies to label to to get
some data label data secondly you can
generate new labels by semi-supervised
learning so if you have some label data
set you can do a nearest neighbor and
you can you can say you can label some
of the unlabeled data set as well this
is semi-supervised learning a colleague
of mine yesterday Andreas he
about Gantz to do semi-supervised
learning the third thing is actually
against you can use guns to make fake
data set actually a very good research
paper is from Facebook ai hallucinating
features for using guns and then comes
the metric of parameter based there are
four papers these are I just use four
papers these are the most popular papers
that you can get first thing is from
Siamese networks by Kok as ml and Ruslan
cilok second thing is memory augmented
networks matching networks and meta
optimization I'll talk in depth in deep
in the next few minutes right so related
work these are the inspiration works
that has been done before before people
jump into a few short learning first
papers came from phi phi li in between
2003 and 2006 he talked about Bayesian
learning you and basically what he told
was you can previously learn classes can
be leveraged to help forecast future
once very patient concept but in terms
of images second name thing was been at
lake this paper basically will
revolutionized the few short learning
methods he koi his paper is about
hierarchical bayesian programming
program learning basically learning
through concept learning through
probabilistic programming so if you see
an example here this is a sentence with
letter ohm so what he is trying to do is
he's trying to decompose this full
letter for letter into individual
patterns individual patterns here and
also the pen strokes so basically he's
giving you his giving feature
information to the network and in the
end i'll show you the evaluation and but
this with his work he got very close to
human performance and now comes the
paper summaries
it's the first paper summer is about
Siamese neural networks either this is
only for one shot a minute recognition
so what these guys do this this is very
ingenious paper back in at 2015 just
after Bennett Lakes paper what these
guys did was they created verification
networks so in your in your test tasks
you basically basically give image pairs
basically here a football in a football
and the and the classifier needs to
predict if it's the same image or a
different image so it give image pairs
football in football football a
crocodile different elephant elephant
same elephant crocodile different so
from his sample set you just create test
pairs and then he feed it into the
network he also did some experiments
with voices and trying to disperse if
it's the same noise or different finally
during the test test you also need to
give test pairs because it's obvious so
you give a basketball and a polar bear
but different basketball and basketball
should be the same so this is your test
task so how does this network look like
basically it's Siamese Network Siamese
twins as you say it's a very small Ciena
network very simple some convolutions
some max pooling some Ray Lewis stacked
on top of each other so you get into the
feed the image Omniglot in this case
finally get a 4 or 4096 vector of of the
image representation what you do is you
take the equilibrium distance between
the two two images and then you make a
sigmoid on top of it basically Sigma it
may makes a binary classification if
it's the same image or a different image
basically tool presentations are they
are the same or not I'm not going deep
into mathematics because time constraint
all also the code because there's a lot
of code available online as well so you
can just hook up onto that so here you
see the evaluation metrics what it says
is the second one is H we feel by
bernard lake if you see the humor the
performance is very close to humans or
and if you see the convolution Siamese
Siamese net
this was done by [ __ ] ml select
differences are there they reached a
performance of 92% accuracy the
baselines were then the baselines were
basically can and nearest neighbors
which is here which reads around twenty
one point seven all right so before
going on to the next
that was so this is are these summaries
that I'm going to give you very very
short very brief second concept second
paper before I go to the second paper
I'm gonna talk about some concepts
because all these next papers they use
these concepts the first concept is of
episodes because when you're trying to
train a new network all the newspapers
will try to use episodic learning so
what is an episode you show an image and
in the next time step you show the label
of the image and then you forego on so
you show an image you you get the label
and basically at every time step at the
next time step you're asking the network
to predict the label and then if the if
the prediction is wrong with the with
the class then in backdrops and updates
the weights of the network same as that
so and typically people have been using
five five platter five classes of images
in one sample these range from five to
twenty the next concept is about meta
learning meta learning is a it's a big
topic it can be a paper on its own a
topic on its own PI data what they do is
what is meta learning and meta learning
is about learning from trying to combine
learning from previously learn data to a
new learner so they are to optimize
optimizations that you need to do their
learning which is the learner which is
learning a new task and the meta learner
which has which is trying to train the
network trying to train the learner so
it's simple there is a learner there's a
class classifier that you have built and
then you want to hook up meta learner
which is trying to teach the this
classifier how to proceed further
basically how to optimize the weights
in this example this is people from
rubbing in La Rochelle which I'm going
to talk about in the end they're trying
to do meta learning here and meta
testing well so in here you see that
they are also doing episode episodic
learning of five images so you show five
images here and then in the test at the
test set it can also vary two to five
this is very different from the
conventional machine learning that we
try to do here as normally that we do
would normally what we have is that it's
the whole dataset we split it into
training and testing but basically the
classes that you have in training should
be there in the testing data set meta
learning is very different because
Ukraine or certain number of classes but
on the testing set it can be a different
class
sorry MB in the meta testing phase there
can be a total different number of
classes so if you see here there's some
kinds of dogs here some kinds of
mushrooms but in the meta testing phase
there are some cups tigers as well so
they samples that the network sees
during the testing phase doesn't need to
be the same in the in the training phase
doesn't need to be the same in the
testing phase next concept is about
neural curing machines this was done by
graves from D pine in 2014 what he
proposed was you have a new network
which is the controller and what you
teach this controller is basically store
information in into the memory so once
you get information to this new network
it saves it into memory and whenever you
ask to retrieve the same information it
goes into the memory and gives you the
information and it's needs to be aware
fast it can you can also update memories
but these neural Turing machines are
very location-based optimized so you
have indexes and then whenever he asks
for the same information it should get
retrieve from the last location
normally in neural to machines you fed
the network sequentially so you had
sequence of data and what the what this
was optimized was least you at least
last used memory location to give the
outputs right that
so these concepts basically triggered
the next papers so the next paper is
about one short learning with memory
augmented networks this was also done my
big mind fellows Santoro and others so
his paper was also very genius so he
said okay I'll use annual Turing machine
but instead of just optimizing using
location I'll try to optimize using
image representations and similarity
between image representations so here in
the in the test setup you basically give
episodes and in different episodes you
shuffle the labels the classes and the
samples right so you have five weeks
five classes now and the next episode
there can be shuffled the the image just
can be shuffled or there can be totally
new classes and what he did was he
hooked up MTM on top of his elysium
network and you fed an image here and in
the next time step you basically fed the
label and then he asked the new MDM to
store the representation of the image
and the class and basically the chain
continued and at every time step it
asked what the what the class label is
and if the class label was wrong
it used a backdrop and update the
network so this was kind of a summary of
this paper in the evaluation phase for
Omniglot he got so you see that at the
first instance of these objects of these
omni god images humans were doing around
34.5 using his memory augmented network
we got 36.4 but if you see the second
one the second instance of this second
instance this this network basically
revolutionized and made it a 22.8 so
from second on it basically jumped the
accuracy levels basically simply jumped
and there was like a lot of commotion
there okay this is really nice
so that brings us to the next paper
matching networks this is this is a my
minions he's also a deep mine fellow
what did it was was also ingenious what
he what he did was okay I'll use an NPM
I'll also use an LCM but instead of just
using a similarity between images
I'll put an attention logic and also
what he proposed was training and test
conditions must match so if you are
showing 5 5 sample of images in one
bucket and during a training phase that
test conditions should also match you
should also show 5 classes in the test
thirdly I'm not I'm not written here he
said humans should not be considered as
baseline here because humans have
learned throughout their lifecycle how
to how to recognize objects images
letters basically if I'm given that
Greek letter I kind of know it's it's a
Greek if it's a Sanskrit I kind of know
ok it can really resemble the Sanskrit
letter so he said humans should not be
there in the evaluation so a bit of
match here so what is there what is the
sample sample is a set of images that
you see x and y do you have some images
and he has some target values what do
you need to do is make a classifier for
a new tower for a new image that should
have a class label from one of these
sample images so give you a classifier
which defines a probability distribution
P for a target clatter for a for a test
for a test image for a for a Y which is
present in the sample dataset so this Y
target class what is it it is basically
an attention mechanism which is a soft
max on the cosine distances and so this
this basically is the is the chunky part
of this paper how the Y here is the 100
encoded values and that's about it so
here also what this G theta and F theta
these are also LS tiems but these are
bi-directional Ella streams and in
bi-directional
seems the sequence really matters so you
can't shuffle the images you need to
have if you're doing buy that from the
images that you that Avedon should also
go in the same sequence backwards so
that was it
and the evaluation if you see now it
from the from the memory augmented you
know networks you see the performance of
eighty two point eight and ninety four
point nine five accuracy and then in
matching networks you basically see
they've he made at 98.1
this was mind blowing at the time he
also said okay opening lot is good
enough but we need to do on real-life
images so he took him an image net and
he got a score of around forty six point
six and four five shot he got sixty
percent accuracy so very well so far so
if you have already got 98% accuracy how
how much can you do better than that and
that brings us kind of to the next paper
optimizes you in as a model for a few
short learning this paper is kind of
very it's like ingenious right because
in all these previous papers you had
multiple networks that that we need to
put into production and as a machine
learning engineer I want to make my life
simpler so I need one if I'm just doing
image classification and if I can just
do it in one network I will just go for
that so this was done by lovey and
Herschel I think they were at that time
working for Twitter I still do not know
where they are right now but Irish
fellas
you can find a lot of YouTube videos so
what he proposed was he used an Ellis
team based metal earner and tried to
optimize a CN n so for in a CNN you're
learning all these parameters and waves
right so we said okay for all these
parameters that are there in this
network you fitted into an LST M and
I'll propose you the next parameter
update
instead of using gradient descent like
at a grad Adam or whatever because these
are really slow so this he just used
hooked up analyst team at learner to
just propose the next network wit the
next thing that he proposed was
initialization of the network from
analyst team as well because if you'd
randomly initialize the CNN it will
converge much later and after a lot of
Reeboks but if you hook up an LSTA and
put the weights initialize the weights
from there it can converge much faster
basically you have already a met a
learner there and you from a different
task and then you hook up to to a CNN
which is learning in another kind of
images and and it will optimize better
as said from that from the paper so this
is very simple structure so on the top
here is here is the learner and on the
big blobs are the many learners so the
learners are a CNN you feed in a in an
image and a target class and the deltas
and the loss functions are basically for
each sample which contains multiple
object and multiple images you get a
loss function for all of them you feed
in the loss to the metal owner and the
metal learner will just propose the next
parameter updates to the CNN so in one
blob it will give you the whole
parameter updates and cycle chain
continues and finally have a good
network and this on the right hand side
you see the test tasks so what he did
was his paper base his paper kind of got
to the same performance as before vini
else matching networks but then still
for me this is really ingenious because
in the end you get one CNN trained
really fast and then you can just put
the CNN into production and your job is
done
and yeah that's about it there are some
more papers that you should look into so
one thing is the last paper that our it
was one-shot imitation learning this was
about
recognising human actions so if I'm
trying to pick up a pick up a bottle the
machine should be able to learn it from
one instance by just seeing my how I
pick up this bottle it should learn that
basic and this network is trained on
many other actions and just showing one
action it the these guys are trying to
train a network and I think these are
also working for a deep mind I'm not
sure the next one is wrong I told you
before loss short visual recognition by
shrinking and hallucinating features in
this paper they are trying to use Gans
to hallucinate and create fake images to
train the network this this goes into
the data domain and not in the parameter
or metric domain and there are some code
bases that you can hook up into and he a
neural Turing machines from this github
code sign these networks this is a very
good blog post using Siamese networks
just to make a test pairs and making a
chaos model you can just make a Karass
model and then get a cue leading
distances from the future future matrix
last thing the business value what do
you do okay here we are doing few short
learning but why should we do it first
thing is you would have used your new
Samsung and Apple phones and now they do
facial recognition right they have many
other features put into place but one of
these things is they just take one
picture and from one picture they can
recognize if it's the same face or a
different face so this is one example
for for OLX it was trying to recognize
trying to moderate items which are not
shown so I come from a fraud domain and
the number of classes that we have for
fraud is very less and for images even
even s so how do we train Network and so
we have to follow these kind of
principles either going through the data
domain or the metric domain to create a
network and
that's about it if you have any
questions I hope I finished on time I
still I think I have five minutes more
left but if any if you have any more
questions please go ahead
[Applause]
Ming we have 10 minutes for questions so
yeah please yeah can you just wait for
the mic please
I have a question about these CMI's
networks so there were two convolutional
nets and are they trained independently
or are they the same networks or how it
works and so the question is in when you
are training a sign isn't it networks do
you train the both the network's at the
same time and the answer is yes so you
back drop at the same time okay so you
have two networks basically you can
easily make using Harris you have to
CNN's and a merge layer at the bottom
basically you have a sigmoid layer right
so the whole backdrop should go back to
the top to the first layer so you train
the whole network in one go so you put
an image pair you go through the cnn's
and max pooling everything you get in
representation and then you need to put
a sigmoid layer at the end and if the
sigmoid layer is making a bad decision
it needs to go back drop and fix all the
weights in the networks thank you
any more questions I hope I made this
concept very simple and plain English I
didn't want to put in a lot of maths
because maybe I would get stuck as well
here kind of following up on something
that's already been mentioned but can
you talk a bit more about like different
applications that you've found for for
this kind of approaches so far maybe
even in your in your current work so
this gentleman is asking if what are the
current business values of how can what
are the practical applications right in
my current job it is basically in OLX
you get well X is a classifieds market
so you get a lot of objects a lot of
listings coming to you so if you want to
sell your jacket if you want to sell it
basically if you want to sell flasks
or something or computer you get lots of
categories coming in there sometimes
there are new categories coming onto
your platform and need to learn them
basically so that you can improve the
search on the platform
second thing is moderation there are
some kinds of objects let's say there's
we're dealing with so many countries and
there are certain forbidden items in
every country in Poland it is this
cigarette vaporizers okay so you cannot
sell cigarette revisers in Poland and
you need to recognize these objects
sometimes you can get these images
easily from Google but sometimes they
are not so many images available so you
need to do these kind of approaches
there industry standard is mainly about
facial recognition and trying to trying
to make CNN networks just learn faster
using some small number of examples
because in the end if you are training a
new network you need to learn a lot of
examples this goes on to
self-driving cars as well because you
need to learn a lot of you need to make
your car go around a lot of tracks get a
lot of images trying to learn from them
so if you can learn it faster it's
always better
hi I'm coming from the insurance
industry and so the problem we are
facing in fraud fighting is to recognize
the same damage which is always unique
so do you have any recommendation maybe
which one of the structures that you
present it would be suitable method
since we also have very few instances of
the same but a class which is a damage
practical approach is that I would say
these papers are really good but then it
is very difficult to implement them if
you can implement them sorry I will
repeat the question so the question is
that in insurance people are posting
pictures of car damages and they might
not be and these all damages are quite
unique because you can hit a car in any
direction and they might be like front
bumper then so how do you classify them
because there are very few examples my
current approach would be use the data
domain trying to helis innate features
from images basically create more data
set to train a network because all these
the research train that is currently
going on is still going on and these are
still very still very academic not
production-ready yet if you can if you
can use we use the Facebook paper here
the second one here to elucidate
features this can really help you but
still you have to implement the paper
from scratch so I think there's a
parallel track how to implement a paper
and what are the learnings from that
is it okay if I have another question so
what we were trying to implement is a
paper on deep ranking do you have any
experience with it with Triplets of
images triplets also triple F triplet
loss is was in I think invented by
Facebook that they were trying to do
facial recognition in all these pictures
so I make a tag on my image and then it
was trying to recognize all these images
in all my pictures that is also very
good but then you need to have always in
there triplet when you when you're
training this triplet networks you need
to create all these triplet pair
triplets right so you need to have two
two images same and the third image a
different image in order to okay this is
a very good network but to get this data
set is very difficult you need to work a
lot to make this data set and that is
the most problematic way for phrase for
Facebook it was quite easy because you
get so many images on their platform and
they can they have these software
engineers who can make this data set to
train on I hope that answered your
question it is of course not the perfect
answer but yeah you have to try Aero
ways to do it
for the last paper you presented there
was this meta strategy that provides the
parameters could you explain a little
bit more how this is trained or how it
knows in which way to optimize the
parameters okay so basically this this
is the this is the picture here as I
expand if you read the paper it can
explain you much better and like yeah
you can come up to the desk and I can
orlick's desk and I can actually in
there so this are in different phases so
here you have a CNN you feed in your
images okay these are just not one image
you're feeding in a sample of images the
sample set can vary from 5 from 1 to 10
when you when you feed it on all these
pictures to the CNN you're getting a
loss on on the on the labels that you
predicted once you have got the loss you
put this loss into the metal earner yes
which you put in the metal earner and
which predicts the final parameters now
there is the thing is CNN's currently
have a lot of parameters so if you just
take an inception net or ResNet this
kind of things will not work you need to
have very simple network very simple CNN
so that your meta learner can learn all
these parameter updates because if you
just choose a big one this meta learner
will explode and cannot do much so it
does a lot in parameter sharing from
different phases and trying to give you
a parameter update and if you read the
paper the paper is not very you need to
read it multiple times to basically
understand the maths behind it but I
really like this
because as I said before you get one CNN
in the end but this is this is just not
like inception that this is the Train
like a three layer or four layer Network
and it is specified how the Train how
the training strategy went I hope
there's one more question okay yes so I
think in the first paper you mentioned
that you were comparing let's say
elephants with elephants and elephants
with four different animal what kind of
detail you can you recognize between the
two images let's say you are comparing
at all documents lines in between can
you also make an assertion in this
direction or is it too detailed if
you're trying to do in that's case so
the question is okay the Siamese
networks we are trying to do very
distinct conceptual different images
from an elephant to a football what if
you have conceptually same kind of
images that you want to differ in that
case I would go for fine-grained
classification and not using assignment
networks you can use sign these networks
as well but you need to do fine-grained
classification and there's a whole
different domain on doing fine written
classification on conceptually similar
kind of images this I mean this network
will I need to train in a lot of epochs
to see if it kind of works in you test
it out I haven't done it so I I do not
have a practical example that can help
you out okay we are out of time for
questions
I'm sure if I Huff will be around for
more questions I'll be at the OLX desk
around that so if you have more
questions you can come up to me so yeah
thanks again thank you Christo's
[Applause]